in Westworld season 2 episode 4 bernard
is dragged on his arse by clementine who
grabbed him last episode she drags him
to a cave that's miles from anywhere
which means a Bernards but must hurt and
be there's a secret here inside Bernard
finds Elsie last season ford programmed
bernard to capture her because she
almost found out ford's plans
apparently Elsie's survived on protein
bars
ever since bernard fries Elsie and she
finds out that Bernard is a host and she
takes the news pretty well that her boss
was a robot all along her curiosity as a
programmer is greater than her fear so
she helps with Bernards brain damage
they find a secret Delos lab like the
lab in episode 1 where drone hosts
record guest data but this lab is
something more
it has James Telos about 30 years ago
James died of a disease but his company
led by William copied his mind into a
robot body a hybrid of human and host
the goal was to make James immortal but
this human host is unstable it keeps
breaking down so the company keeps
burning James and making a new one
achieving a longer life each time over
30 years he is born then dies 149 times
having the same conversation with
William over and over the imagery of a
spinning record and exercise bike and
circular room evoke the loop that James
is trapped in he finds out that his wife
and kids are dead over and over he's
burned alive over and over to the tune
of the Rolling Stones play with fire he
had tried to cheat the devil and live
forever but he ended up in hell by the
time of season 1 Williams wife Juliet
has died and he stopped believing in the
immortality project saying people aren't
meant to live forever so he leaves James
to breakdown and then the robot
revolution happens so there's no one to
terminate James until Bernard and LC
find him two weeks later by then James
is mad and suffering which may be the
closest he's been to alive because one
of the big ideas last season is that
suffering makes hosts conscious and free
so maybe in Jim's
pain and death he felt alive for the
first time in decades so this is a part
of the del los secret project that's
been hinted out all series they're
trying to make humans immortal by
putting their minds in host bodies but
how does this connect to the west-world
guests behavior data recorded in these
labs and whose brains are these two
clone James he has an observation period
and baseline interview they make a
record of who James is so that they can
copy him with high fidelity Westworld is
kind of the same thing William says the
Parc reveals who guests really are
through their choices and sins and Delos
has been watching with this baseline
data
maybe Delos can make human host clones
of all West world guests and as we see
with Jim's script these hybrid hosts are
predictable maybe Delos could use this
technology to control human behavior
this could be glory
dolorous --is weapon Williams mistake
the burning of the species logan
mentions not human like robots but robot
like humans we don't know that details
but glory must be something that
combines humanity and hosts immortality
and control and there's another mystery
here we find out that sometime around
season one Ford sent Bernard to this lab
to kill the techs and make another
hybrid brain of some human whose mind
did they build one possibility is Ford
maybe they'll bring him back but Ford's
death made a point about the end of the
humans and rise of the hosts Ford said
that he'll live on in his music he
exists in the code of his hosts like
Lawrence's daughter and young Robert so
bringing back forward as a hybrid host
would undermine the climax of last
season maybe the host could be a young
William to confront old Bill at the end
of his quest he is told to revisit his
past or maybe this mind will be Arnold's
ford's partner who Bernard is based on
if they want to get tricky it could be
that the Bernard we saw in the wake
ahead timeline in episode 1 is actually
Arnold as a human host hybrid because
he's acting
super-weird and he has flashbacks of
Arnold with Dolores
how could Bernard remember Arnold's life
last season Westworld showed us Arnold
and made us think it was Bernard so
maybe they're pulling the same trick
this season so this hybrid mind might be
Arnold's but there is another
complication what's the data in Peter
Abernathy's head is it a copy of James
Dallas's mind or revoir NAL's mind
Charlotte said there's 35 years of data
in there so maybe it's all the guest
behavior and DNA data that might explain
why Delos needs it so bad William and
Lawrence say Chinese railway worker
hosts who kill their overseers and use
their bodies as railway ties Chinese
railway workers in the real American
West suffered dangerous conditions and
discrimination so along with colonial
India and Confederate slavery West world
explores real historical injustice to
parallel the treatment of hosts
it also looks at violent revenge
personified by Dolores is it justice to
kill your masters or as Maeve suggests
does revenge just make you as bad as
them bill and Lawrence arrive at Los
Morris the home of Lawrence's wife and
daughter Lawrence says that his family
loves him but really he's a son of a
[ __ ] so it's kinder for him to avoid
his family this is similar to Williams
situation he had a wife and daughter but
and he's a bad dude and spent time in
Westworld instead of with them the town
is controlled by a Craddock he holds
court in a church and brags about his
resurrection earlier says he's the
chosen one of death this annoys William
because he believes that death is final
and people shouldn't be brought back and
then Craddock starts murdering and
tormenting the townspeople just like
William did when he was here last season
so bill is faced with his own past sins
and this time he feels some sympathy for
the hosts Lawrence's wife reminds him of
the death of his own wife Juliet so the
man in black takes on the role of death
and kills Craddock and his men in the
rain showrunner Lisa joy says this
represents washing away Bill's past
trying to achieve
Redemption Lawrence's family thanked him
for the help but Lawrence's daughter
speaking as Ford says one good deed
doesn't araise Williams crimes so this
season were getting a morally ambiguous
William last season he was a villain but
now he's trying to make things right as
Lawrence's daughter says if you're
looking for word you're looking in the
wrong direction
William is facing his past we see grace
the woman from the Raj lost episode
she's been captured by ghost nation
along with some guests from Season one
tourists who get more than they
bargained for
there's also stops captured last season
he says that while Ghost Nation does
kill hosts they don't kill humans ghost
nation takes their prisoners to a catch
eater who they call the first of us
maybe a cachito was the first ghost
nation host created we do see him as an
early host in Episode two grace escapes
then a catcher to threaten Stubbs and
says you only live as long as the last
person who remembers you which connects
to the themes of legacy and immortality
with James
then the ghost nation hosts disappear
apparently letting Stubbs leaf and meet
up with Delos for the week ahead
timeline why would ghost nation capture
humans then let them go these hosts
programmed or free are they protecting
humans or doing something else we still
don't know in the end grace meets
William and reveals that she is his
daughter Emily
maybe grace is a fake name we know from
last season that Emily and William have
a difficult relationship she blames Bill
for the suicide of her mother Juliet and
bill says his daughter would probably
like to see him gunned down so this
isn't the happiest reunion but bill and
Emily seem to have the same goal to
reach glory symbolized by this hexagonal
pattern that appears in Delos labs now
that we know about James's immortality
project this symbol almost looks like an
infinity sign or an hourglass tipped on
its side William and grace might need to
work together to reach the mystery at
the center of this season thank you for
watching and thanks to the patrons
including Melinda Rubin Matthew Athey is
right
have Gareth foot and hey buds Cheers
you